I can tell you you know cuz I was
talking earlier about Cassandra
Fairbanks a bunch of bunch of
conservatives are really angry they're
very pro Israel and I'm like dude the
the the uh uh this company and the work
that I do is not pred predicated upon
the history of Gaza and Israel right and
so what ends up happening is you have
these people who for some reason have a
large portion of their identity rooted
in which side is correct and which side
is wrong true and so they'll come out
and they'll assert one side has you know
it's funny because they're like you know
it's it's historically Palestine
therefore you know Israel is the
occupying force and then other people
are like like it was Judea and it was
like Jerusalem the Holy Land are you
crazy and I'm just like I got I can tell
you it's not America and yeah I'm not
from there I don't know man there have
been there's been violence and conflict
over this region for a really long time
including in recent years prior to
October 7th I'm not saying that Israel
shouldn't be able to defend itself of
course it should on the other hand
similarly to the conflict that's been
ongoing between Russia and Ukraine for a
long time is this in the Americans
American people's best interest to wait
into a war which we have very little
cultural understanding of and at the
same time make worse like Joe Biden's
saying yes Gaza I will give you money
also Israel I'll send some troops in we
don't know what side we're going to be
on and ultimately we're not going to
make anyone happy we're only going to
ask certain what side we're going to be
on I certainly hope we're going to be on
the side of our allies well all are
committing war crimes what war crimes
are they committing well if you're
seeing the reports of white phosphorus
being uh in so you're taking word no no
no no no no but I'm taking reports on
the ground I you know I'm Jewish and I
just don't want anyone I don't want a
trity being conducted against anybody I
don't want any more Israeli lives to be
uh taken I don't want any more
Palestinian lives to be taken especially
innocent children that we're seeing and
so many times I'm saying this online and
people are saying oh so you're Pro Hamas
or you know you're Pro sympath
sympathizer for terrorist no not at all
but I don't want I don't want any
Innocents to die and I'm seeing White
forus being rained down and one in 20
buildings in Gaza is are leveled and you
you're seeing more bombs being dropped
on Gaza than were dropped in the entire
first year in the Afghanistan war and so
I and those are war crimes okay because
when you have what war crime what does
that mean Collective punishment defined
by the Geneva Convention is to punish an
entire group of people innocent people
for the crimes of especially this a
terror group it's the government though
Hamas was elected to lead the government
but there hasn't been a fair election in
a decade but the I think the we we
pulled this up too the recent surveys
show that 51% of people in Gaza support
Hamas and so yeah I'm not going to blame
the civilians there's a lot of really uh
awful videos that are coming out but
I'll tell you exactly where I'm at uh I
don't know anything about the region for
the most part I mean obviously I do know
a bit about the region but uh I have no
vested interest in the outcome in the
region I I am not here to be like the
history of Israel or Israel this Israel
that or Palestine this Palestine that I
can tell you that on October 7th a
horrifying terror attack occurred in
which Hamas tore through the fences went
in and started massacring civilians
Israel's released some of this footage
we got a bunch of this footage and then
what I end up hearing from people is
yeah well I bet Israel knew and I'm like
how did we shift from we quite literally
have video of civilians being gunned
down in their car and people burning
down homes and children being killed and
the response immediately is yeah but I
bet net now knew about it because he was
doing it to benefit himself and it's
like no no no no no no no no no we are
so far from that conversation the
conversation is right now Israel was
attacked innocent civilians were killed
uh uh Max Blumenthal came on and said
Hamas targeted the civilians because
it's opportunistic for them it's part of
their Doctrine to Target civilians to
use as as bargaining chips against
Israel and then after that is the
beginning and opening premise I have
people complaining about Israel and I'm
like yeah you know yeah Israel's
probably doing a lot of bad stuff it's
it's it's this is what happens when you
declare war on someone Hamas declared
war on Israel Israel is the PowerHouse
with the fourth most powerful Army so
they say with support from Western
powers and Hamas decided to declare war
now a lot of people then go yeah well
you know it's an open air prison and
blah blah blah I'm like you lost me
already I am not Israel I am not
Palestine I am the United States of
America I am an individual here and I
can't tell about the history of the
region I can tell you if they did not
tear down those fences storm in and
Massacre a thousand plus civilians there
would not be bombings in Gaza that's
right does not mean Israel should be
indiscriminately targeting anybody but
then the argument from the pro-israel
side is we are not just trying to Target
and and we are not trying to take out
civilians and then I can tell you this
after all the dust settles Hamas and the
left have lied about almost everything
so when someone comes says Israel's
engaged in war crimes I go hospital and
they go yeah but hospital hospital was
fake they lied it didn't happen and we
were so busy tricked into arguing over
who did it we never stopped to ask
ourselves did it even happen and the
answer was it did not well from the
beginning of the conflict I've been
saying nothing nothing but I want peace
I condemn Hamas I even went as far as
saying F Hamas on my Twitter and but I
but I think things still have to be
pointed out Israel is a formalized
government Palestine is not nobody takes
the Palestinian government serious so
when you know bombs are being dropped on
residential buildings in Gaza you have
to point that out and if you say that
Hamas is using those to protect whatever
they have there inside well you know
Israel's very capable of going in with
Insurgent teams and getting out or
killing whoever they need to the West
supplies them with a ton of money and a
ton of training with our armed forces
and so I think they're perfectly capable
of going in I don't see a need for
leveling an entire building and You' and
the problem is I don't think you'd see
the reaction that you're talking about
if you didn't have Evangelical
Christians on Twitter saying glass Gaza
you know te make it a parking lot like
this incendiary rhetoric that just has
no care for human regard because it's
more about Humanity than anything I
could care less if it's Israeli or
Palestinian it's about humanity and
people are being killed at rates you've
never seen before 2014 88 Israelis died
and
2329 Palestinians died no one was
calling it no one was calling you know
what's going on over there in the Middle
East we should get involved I I don't
think comparing the total number of dead
answers the question of what how or why
and does not indicate justification or I
just don't like how the media covers it
differently because the first time you
have an Israeli attack then it's like oh
my gosh the world's ending World War III
but Palestinians have been being killed
for years and you're having no coverage
of it and that's that statistic I just
gave you that's one Israeli for every 27
Palestinian that doesn't mean anything
well it does to me because for a decade
20 times more Palestinians have been
killed So when you say why right so but
hold on uh who are these Palestinians
they're Innocents civilians how but like
so this is the issue I take with it I am
the United States I am not Israel or
Palestine I know that Hamas just invaded
killed a whole bunch of civilians Israel
responded Hamas lied about a hospital
being leveled and 500 people dying
totally fabricated Hamas is wrong and so
now the premise any point you initiate
uh Israel's blunt up buildings lie not
interested prove it I I I took Hamas at
face valy boy was that a mistake when
they said it was an Israeli air strike
we we were actually aring like wow could
it have been an air strike I mean we
don't we don't even know I mean oh oh
man and then it was a Hamas rocket
likely misfired and then the payload
dropped into a parking lot killing
killing people that's John France said
it was 10 to 50 people and maybe maybe
it was a parking lot we have no idea
look those are the reports so then I
hear yeah but what about wi white
phosphorus bro I'm sorry but the people
marching through the street who are
saying from The River To The Sea who
have who lied about this Hospital get
zero benefit of the doubt from me and
that means the only word I have is
Israel's and I don't even trust them
well all I can say is we don't want
collateral want wantan deaths want want
thect to the arum then becomes should
Israel strike or they s in a ground
Strike Force to start executing Hamas
AOC effectively called for that yeah
saying we want precision and
intelligence so so so Israel should
invade Gaza if if they're going to
defend themselves they should not be
bombing where there's a ton of Civilian
casualties they told everyone to leave
and Hamas told everyone to but I saw
reports of people who saying my mom is
bedridden because she's sick and she
can't get up what are we supposed to do
some people have no form of getting
anywhere and they're just supposed to
see on Hebrew television that they're
supposed to get up and go somewhere I
think that's I think that's unrealistic
it's not just on television well where
else is it I mean they they put stuff
out like there's been a lot more of that
they went to the UN they told the UN
like get people evacuated from this area
the UN spoke to you know representatives
in Gaza they have diplomatic
channels like a week ago and the UN was
like it would be very difficult to move
a million people at once I mean it's
it's an incredibly difficult ult
situation I think Hamas lies I think
this is a lot of violence but if we're
going to return to the premise of does
America help because like we've talked
about if Joe bid's going to give
whatever millions of dollars to the
Palestinians but we know ultimately
that'll probably end up in the hands of
Hamas but then we're also saying Israel
we're your ally we're not did you hear
what he said last week what Biden said
last week when he gave that speech I
think it was
on Thursday I think it was Thursday and
he said uh you know we're going to give
a bunch of Aid to Gaza and if Hamas
doesn't steal it we'll give we did that
here and it was what are you even
talking about what do you mean like
obviously they're going to take it they
take all of it but also like he knows
that and he's still trying to play Both
Sides this is something that we're
seeing I find that more infuriating I'm
much happier to give money to our allies
and not give money to our enemies I
would rather give money to the Americans
in America than to we already did that I
don't want to do that both sides of a
war that we are now easier to
es I don't like that American and
British Western Munitions are being used
to kill innocent people I think the
human loss and the toll that that
is in any world in any world where
morality and ethics exist means we if
Israel is going to defend themselves
they send in Insurgent teams they kill
who they need to kill whoever caused
whatever attacks took place that's what
they do they they don't risk it they
don't risk it with announcements saying
leave Gaza leave the pl where are they
supposed to go to tent cities for them
to bomb and GL why any of their allies
take in refugees from because I think
Gaza well King Abdullah from Jordan said
that he doesn't want to do it because he
sees it as kind of enabling them Israel
to take over Palestine such a great
reason that's a great way to say that I
thought we learned open borders
everywhere I thought that was the answer
I thought open here in America only to
destroy our country okay so now you're
an American understand as I have now
said several times when your
neighborhood is like being rided you
just leave your front door unlocked and
then go defend someone else's house it
doesn't makes sense I I I I'm just
genuinely curious why the why people are
so uh fervent why there is so much
fervor over Israel Palestine I know I
couldn't tell you as a Jew I don't want
to see my fellow Jew die and I I I think
it's sick I thought after the Hamas
attacks all the Carnage that was left
the pictures that you saw on Twitter
like I was telling you before the show
you're seeing nothing but graphic
footage all around Twitter the Carnage
that was left behind by Hamas is
Despicable and the consequence for that
should be they should be killed but it
again should be just them that are
killed Not Innocent kids suppose the
challenge is like Israel's choices after
being attacked are air strikes on
strategic targets which results in a lot
of collateral damage and and dead
civilians and that's horrifying or
Invasion I don't know pick one me I'm
kind of just like I don't know I'm I'm
not Israel and I'm not in this war and
the United States is is is partially I
suppose tangentially involved in this
war and I think we shouldn't be because
it's an unsolvable issue I just think if
if you've got I just Trump on this if oh
I mean sure I mean but if you've got 51%
of Gaza saying they support Hamas and
even in the United States these people
are chanting from The River To The Sea
peace is not an option I mean peace is
the preferred outcome but it's not an
option when you have one side Sayang
from The River To The Sea yeah but the
majority of those Folks at least I like
to think are not going to go out and
actually plant a bomb like I think that
justifying any war on Gaza because those
folks are so you know critical against
Israel that doesn't justify kill that's
not it that's Hamas using schools and
hospitals to store weapons and to launch
rockets and then attacking Israeli
civilians because as that yel professor
said settlers aren't civilians so to the
people uh to 51% of people in Gaza let's
just say 51% supporting Hamas anyone
anyone some of those people were
tourists fair game kill them all that's
what they're doing that's horrifying
you're not going to get peace in in
Israel with Israel and Palestine if if
that is the view of a million people in
the Gaza Strip right yeah and I so so
what is what is what is Israel's plan um
let me ask you what do you think would
happen if the barrier fencing around
Gaza was completely removed and Israel
just said anyone in Gaza can do whatever
they want they can they can freely
travel freely travel well I mean that
kind of exists now they're able to go
back and forth for jobs no no no no no
I'm saying the barrier if what would
happen if the barrier was completely
removed security around the Gaza Strip
was removed and Israel said to all of
the people you can freely move about all
of Israel what would happen I'm sure
there would probably be conflict going
both ways because both yes both ways
because I've seen uh Hamas and
Palestinian you think Israeli Israelis
in like Tel Aviv will March into Gaza
with guns are killing civilians I think
violence will be conducted either way I
think that I've seen IDF soldiers
treating Palestinian kids very badly on
the streets and and sometimes they brag
about you know doing brutal things to
them I think think it would go both ways
regardless of the situation so if the
offenses were removed Israelis would go
into Gaza I'm not saying just Israelis I
said I know both ways that means so that
the implied is Palestinian civilians
will go into Israeli settlements and
start killing people but you also think
Israeli civilians will go into Gaza and
start killing people I didn't say that I
just think that the conflict would go
both ways I don't think it would be good
for anyone but what does that mean both
ways I think that you know Terror or any
act of violence would be carried out
both ways by both parties but I don't
know what that means like you think the
people in the Gaza Strip would they
leave the Gaza Strip if the barriers
removed and security is removed and they
say you can freely move about I don't
think a lot of them would they just stay
there I mean I'm sure there would be
some tension for sure but I don't think
a lot of them would leave the homes you
think the people in Gaza would just stay
there so it's not an open air prison
well if you're saying that Palestinians
now can't go to Israel that they can I
mean and I don't think a barrier makes
much of a difference if you can get
through to it to go to your job from 9
to 5 so then then so it's not an open
air prison and the complaints of the
Palestinians are just exaggerations well
I think that the land the land conflict
is a whole another topic I mean what
belongs to who that's just a whole
another can of worms I don't want to get
into but I don't think a barrier there
is what's stopping any specific thing I
think people are able to go free and
easy regardless so the issue I suppose
is leftists are calling it an open air
prison where people are trapped and
stripped of resources well in a way they
are and that's another War crime you
mentioned because so it's a war crime
that they're trapped in there well it's
a war crime what's happening now where
electricity water food and Aid is being
cut off but they can just leave but
that's a war crime no no no no no it's
not if they can just leave right that is
an area where people live innocent
people live and so when you cut off
electricity who's giving them
electricity well Israel so they're
obligated to give free electricity to
people of Gaza well when they oversee
certain supply routes they're able to
cut off food no but people can just
leave Gaza you said right they can but
they don't want to give up their land
again they don't want to go to a tent
city and some desert and then have the
land that they had in Gaza be taken over
as well I I I'm not I'm not sure I'm
following so so Israel is providing
electricity to Gaza under what
obligation do the Israelis have to give
a resource to the people of Gaza and how
is it a war crime if they decide to stop
supplying a resource it's a war crime
because those those routes those
electricity routes those trading routes
where they get their food they get their
water go through Israel so when Israel
the Israeli government cuts it off
that's a war crime why how's it a war
crime because you're disallowing
innocent civilians from having drinking
water from having electricity but so
you're saying that it's actually it's
not Israel isn't producing the
electricity they're just going in
between where Gaza would get I know a
lot of the supply routes are not just
coming from Israel I don't think there's
a lot of Israeli yeah I think they're
coming froming right so so Egypt is
trying to get electricity to Gaza but
then Israel is stopping it uh I think
EGP Egypt is trying to get Aid and food
and water and resources and medical
resources to people and Israel stopping
it how the electricity grid there works
I have no idea but I know isra Israeli
uh technology capability does not um
stop it being able to shut down a power
grid I'm I'm I'm not sure I I I I follow
criticism of Israel in this line of
thinking so if if people can can come
and go as they please but they don't
want to live in a tent city so they
would choose to live somewhere with
electricity it's a war crime well no but
you got to look at it like let's let's
make it out like it's here if you
know you know I live in Georgia if
Alabama decided
to you know attack Georgia and come in
here and say well you you gota you got
to leave or you're not going to have
food or water or
resources I don't want my land to be
taken over so I'm going to fight against
those people in order to prevent my land
from being taken over in order to get
resources once again if your land's
already been taken his historically yeah
but why has why have the Palestinians
rejected a two-state solution going back
into the 70s and even
previously again I don't when it when it
comes to the land conflict I think that
they don't really see they don't really
see Israel having any claim over the
land right they they don't want Israel
to exist right that's not okay however
that doesn't justify a war crime to cut
off but what are they so what should
what should Israel what should is do
when they're when they have neighbors
not just not just in Gaza and the West
Bank not just the Palestinians that
don't think they have a right to exist
but they had a long-standing conflict
with Egypt they've had long-standing
enemies in Lebanon they have an they're
they're the only nation in the entire
region right and they have enemies
surrounding them so when you had Trump's
Administration come in with the Abraham
Accords creating the bilateral
agreements that was starting to be
effective we recently had Saudi Arabia
and Israel most normalizing relations
you if Israel can't even play soccer in
the Middle East League they have to play
in Europe because otherwise they would
get killed right by like and Hamas Hamas
engaged in the attack they did to stop
the Abraham Accord yes negotiations and
to stop Saudi Arabia and Israel from
getting close because the Abraham
Accords essentially left the
Palestinians out of it why were the
Palestinians left out of it because they
have refused to come to a negotiating
table at any point with a consideration
of a two- State solution so we've had
Bill Clinton proposed a two-state
solution he had this idea that actually
gave Palestinians a whole bunch of stuff
that they wanted and who was it then it
was Yasir Arafat and Arafat was like nah
we're not going to do that uh you had
Obama had a two-state solution and so
finally Trump just ignored them and they
don't like that either and that's when
they lashed out and killed 1,400 people
including a whole bunch of civilians
children and so now you're saying that
there should be a ceasefire because is
Israel shouldn't be fighting against the
people who are actively seeking their
extermination the problem is there are
Jews in Israeli Israeli Jews who believe
that Palestine shouldn't exist and that
they should have more of a land claim so
to make this whole thing to make this
whole thing ideologically based I think
is the wrong route to go people are
killing each other innocent people are
dying so everyone should want to
ceasefire we can come to the table as
countries diplomatically after but like
you said the biggest ISS right now is to
focus on the civilians that are
dying before we uh we came up here the
crew downstairs was watching a show
called Golden Balls that was great that
was great what Golden Balls you missed
it Han you missed sorry I was working
well we were watching on the big screen
we were watching Golden Balls on the big
screen Golden Balls is a is a British
game show that fills me with righteous
IND IGN indignation and fury but is it
race based because it's British so
everybody gets uh some Golden Balls and
then in like the first round they're
like you show two of them and they have
dollar values and the goal is to build
up a big jackpot and then two of them
you don't see and you have to lie about
what they're worth you claim that oh if
you if you if you pick me I have 10,000s
and whatever in the end the way the game
works the reason why I bring it up you
there are four there are two balls in
front of each person two people left and
one of them is steel the prize model and
one of them is split the prize money if
both players agree to split the prize
money they split the prize money if one
player splits the prize money but the
other steals it the person who steals it
gets it all if both players try to steal
it they get nothing right so you see two
people look each other in the eyes and
say we're going to split the money we're
going to split it I I will take half the
jackpot that's fine with me and they go
yes and then the game game show host
says choose your ball steal the money or
split the money and then they shake
hands and they're like we're going to
split it yep and then they both open
steel they lied the whole time it's
particularly brutal when one person says
I'm going to split the money with you
and then it gets stolen from them and
they I knew it and you know what you
learn from that people evil exists yes
it does and then the people who choose
to steal the money from the other person
go yes yeah and so here's what I see I
see these leftists marching through the
street they lie every every time every
time the Hamas Hospital thing really
pissed me off yeah and then they go uh
uh they they rip through the fences
Massacre civilians watch the videos yeah
and then they go please help us please
they're shooting us and I'm just like
y'all y'all started a fight and you're
losing and now I'm supposed to be mad at
the person who's who's winning if if a
guy breaks into my house with a baton
and I've got a Remington 12 gauge people
are going to be like don't leave him
alone you have a shotgun dude broke into
my house with the weapon Israel gets
attacked and they go but 75 years ago 75
years ago nothing I got no idea what
you're talking about okay how about we
stop fighting right now if the argument
is civilians should stop dying then
Hamas is the problem and the if the
argument is we should have peace between
Palestine and Israel well the problem
that is that Hamas exists and so long as
there is someone who's going to steal
the money from the other person and lie
about it there's not going to be a peace
agreement any other argument is
pointless the people who are like Israel
is engaged in war crimes blah blah blah
I'm like dude there's a war going on and
and and one side is lying about
everything and started the fight and is
actively trying to Massacre civilians
arguing that every civilian is a
colonizer and from The River To The Sea
they're going to reclaim this land I'm
sorry dude peace agreements sound like a
psychotic proposal there's a man
standing before you at the front of your
house saying if you let me in your house
I will do unspeakable things to your
children and then people are like just
let them in just just let them in
negotiate you're kicking him outside
he's got no electricity outside you've
cut him off from warmth and heating in
Air Condition it's a war crime crime and
I'm like he's going to come in here he's
going to kill everybody no no you're
you're you're committing a war crime by
not giving him stuff and I'm just like
dude I I can't do this what if hear me
out we had the leaders of Hamas
Palestine and Israel get together go on
Golden Balls and see if this settles the
conflict maybe there is a way to just
get out of this using British ENT is out
of the question when Trump was in office
get out of it using British
entertainment chall I really think it's
an underrated geopolitical diplomatic
resource you cannot argue for peace
after Hamas massacres a bunch of CI
civilians starting the conflict and
still right now despite everything going
on keeps telling everyone they will kill
Israelis no matter what thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8:00 pm and become a
member over at timcast.net